we can come together to solve the
housing affordability crisis
thank you
[Music]
hello i'm councilwoman laura pastored
from phoenix arizona
i'm happy to join you at this year's
congressional city conference
where we'll discuss ways to partner with
the federal government to help rebuild
our nation's crumbling
infrastructure continue to connect our
regions
and create new technology solutions
before covet 19 we knew much of our
nation's infrastructure was in dire need
of repair
improvement and modernization the
pandemic
has forced local government budgets to
either delay or cancel
critical infrastructure investments this
is why
now more than ever the federal
government must prioritize
infrastructure
development not only to repair our
nation's since deteriorating roads
bridges railways and ports
but to spur job creation and local
activity to move our nation's economic
recovery ahead
we must also ensure our residents have
full broadband access to stay connected
not isolated while social distancing we
need
america to get back to work and urge our
federal partners to support our
communities with grants
tools and resources for infrastructure
projects
and i look forward to working with all
of you in keeping
america moving now
to come and in the words of one of
national neighbors civil rights activist
dolores huerta si se puede
[Music]
please welcome representative peter
defazio chair of the house
transportation and infrastructure
committee
[Music]
you know it's a new era we went through
seven
fake infrastructure weeks with trump the
net proposals out of the trump
administration
would have cut investment in service
transportation dj griffin would have
said hey it's the responsibility of the
states and the localities
that doesn't work i have a poster many
of you have seen it
it's uh you know it's a visual shot from
life magazine 1956.
and it shows a brand new ribbon of
concrete that's kansas turnpike and it
ends
in like all these kind of lines and you
what's that
oh that's amos schweitzer's farm field
uh
oklahoma promised to build it but they
got in financial difficulty and they
couldn't
until we had the eisenhower plan the
eisenhower plan was great
for the time but it's time to move
beyond the eisenhower plan i'm not doing
eisenhower plan 7.0 this is the 21st
century in america
we have all incredibly new challenges
and threats including climate change
and we can deal with economic recovery
climate change and rebuilding our
infrastructure
all in one bill with your help
my bill would invest 500 billion dollars
over five years 44 increase 49 billion
dedicated to local areas i know that a
lot of times you struggle with your
states to get the funding you need from
meritorious local projects we're going
to direct more money
down to your level 105 billion over five
years
for transit and and transportation
programs
we're going to have locally driven
discretionary grant programs
communities of all sizes and a new
metropolitan performance program to
provide
flexible federal funding
directly to regions options that go
beyond
the car truly multimodal micro modal
all those things are in this bill we
have as secretary of transportation who
was a mayor
he knows about complete streets we're
doing with
we're dealing with appropriate design
and complete streets in the spill
we've got to help people get out of
their cars and more people will get out
of their cars
if it's safer and more convenient to use
active transportation
other than an automobile and more people
will get out of their cars if we have
dependable more accessible and more
frequent transit
uh with you know with a 100 billion
dollar backlog for state of good repair
people don't take they say i got you
work time
train broke down sorry boss uh no it
doesn't work
uh so bring it up to a state of good
repair and extend new transit options to
people all at the same time
as we de-fossilize uh we've got to move
beyond the fossil fuel economy the
largest contributor
uh to fossil fuel pollution in the
united states of america is
transportation
this bill will deal meaningfully with
that by electrifying the national
highway network
we're going to partner with the energy
and commerce committee
we want to have electric buses and
cities uh we want to the
electric semis are coming there is no
charging station
anywhere in america for an electric semi
right now
and there's only 5 000 high
high-capacity chargers
for individual vehicles small trucks etc
uh the president's talked about 500 000
chargers i don't know if that's enough
but we are going to do this and we're
going to do it with renewable power you
don't gain a lot when you charge
your car from a coal plant you gain
something but
not what we want
[Music]
greetings i'm mayor lyle jordan from
federal arkansas
i'm looking forward to speaking with you
all at this year's congressional city
conference
to discuss getting america back to work
to do this we need to see policies from
the federal government
that will ensure our communities play a
central role
in our nation's economic recovery both
before and throughout the pandemic
we've seen the nature of work rapidly
evolve
that have completely transformed our
economy
in response cities need enhanced
workforce training programs
to ensure that we are prepared to take
on the jobs of the future
our america
after historic levels of unemployment
we want to see a federal government that
provides apprenticeship
programs expands financial aid programs
for workforce training skills
and creates new pathways to successful
careers for
unemployed and underemployed americans
here in federal our latest library
expansion
includes a new innovation center where
access to job skill training
opportunities
is as easy as checking out a book the
center includes
a teaching kitchen maker space
robotics lab audio and video
editing suites all at no cost to our
residents
by investing in skills training and wrap
around support for working families
the federal government can help city
leaders
build upon successful workforce
development programs
that strengthen our communities at the
local level
cities are counting on congress and the
biden administration
to empower local workforce solutions so
that
all of our residents have an opportunity
to achieve
meaningful employment at a living wage
thank you all
i'm rich david i'm kathy sheehan i'm
francis x murray mayor of the village of
rockville center
mayor of the city of albany new york
mayor of the city of binghamton
we have been on the front lines of
protecting our community during this
pandemic
providing essential services and taking
extraordinary steps to keep our
residents safe
yet all of america's villages cities and
towns are struggling
not because of anything that we've done
but due to the pandemic
and the economic shutdown it created we
need
help we have done our jobs during this
pandemic we have continued to provide
all the vital services
on top of our current financial
struggles it's projected that
over the next three years municipalities
like ours
across the nation we'll see over 360
billion dollars in lost revenues
leading to budget cuts service
reductions and job loss
these losses aren't just numbers they
will be
our families our friends our communities
and frontline workers
providing direct and flexible aid to
municipalities is the most effective and
immediate way to help families who have
been suffering for far
too long the aid will allow us to
maintain our significant contribution to
our local economy by preserving
critical public sector jobs and
supporting local businesses
i believe unemployment prevention and
relief must be a key part of the
upcoming covet relief package
leaving local aid out package will only
lead to greater unemployment
community needs should not be painted in
partisan terms red blue or purple
all states all municipalities are
feeling the pain that has been caused by
this pandemic
and every state in the nation has
communities that look just like ours the
fact is
our community has been left out of each
previous round of government relief
it is way past time for congress to step
up and provide direct aid
to us and municipalities america
can build that better if local
governments are
[Music]
supposedly
[Music]
everybody i am randall woodfin and i
serve as mayor of birmingham alabama
many communities city leaders have been
working around the clock
to keep our residents safe during the
covet 19 pandemic
this last year has shown the importance
of efforts at the local
and federal level to reform and
reimagine public safety
and policing to address long-standing
inequities
endangering our communities
recognize another public health crisis
in our neighborhoods
the epidemic of gun violence that claims
many lives
each year since the beginning of the
pandemic
we have seen a rise in gun violence in
cities throughout our nation
that violence threatens to tear apart
the very fabric
of our society that's why it's important
for local leaders to have the tools
needed
to take on this pandemic of gun violence
we want to work with our leaders
in washington to advance common sense
solutions
to protect our communities the national
league of cities is encouraging
the biden administration to convene a
national commission
on gun violence that brings together
stakeholders from across the spectrum
to offer recommendations on ways to
reduce gun violence
in our hometowns now make no mistake
the violence we are seeing in our
communities as a public health crisis
that demands action
we look forward to constructive
conversations between local
state and federal leaders on ways to
enhance
public safety in all our communities
thank you
[Music]
please welcome back nlc president kathy
manus
ccc is always special for many reasons
but one of those is because it says
march women's history month
every year i look forward to meeting my
sisters in service
my fellow women in elected leadership
our experiences are unique and nlc's
women in municipal government gives us a
place to come together
and share those experiences learning and
growing with each other has been so
empowering
this is a landmark year for women in
government
we have a record number of women serving
in congress
and in january our country welcomed the
first
woman sworn into the white house for the
first time
in united states history i don't know
about you
but it still gives me chills thinking
about it
and what it meant for our nation
and now today on national women's
history day
it is my distinct honor to
welcome to nlc and the ccc
stage the vice president of the united
states
kamala harris
thank you council member kathy maynis
for that kind introduction and the
spirit behind it
and to mayor clarence anthony the nlc
board and staff members local leaders
it is truly an honor to join with you
today
and of course as as kathy said we gather
at the
start of an important week um for our
country yes we are honoring the women of
our country and the world
but this is also a week for our country
that could mark a real turning point
in our fight against covet 19. last
weekend
as you know the house of representatives
passed
our american rescue plan it is a plan
that will provide immediate relief
to america's cities towns and villages
and directly to the american people this
past weekend
the senate advanced this landmark
legislation
and very soon the president of the
united states joe biden
will sign the american rescue plan into
law
so for a year now we have faced this
crisis
of almost immeasurable proportions
impacting the health of our communities
the livelihood of our businesses
and the education of our children
through it all
local leaders you have been in the thick
of it
you are the ones who get called when
there aren't enough vaccine doses to go
around
you're the ones fighting to make sure
first responders
can keep their jobs you are working with
teachers and parents
to get schools reopened safely
you are working with small businesses to
keep their doors open
and working at food distribution sites
in what remains of your
spare time being a local leader
has always been a 24 7 job
and this year i know has tested the
limits
and still you keep getting up
every morning and working to make things
better
so on behalf of myself and president
biden
who i think you all know both of us
served as local leaders
we thank you we thank you we thank you
the president and i were preparing to
take office
we knew what you were up against we knew
we needed to be ready to go on day one
so we started working with you to put a
plan in place
to rescue our nation from this pandemic
i'm proud to report that we've made
incredible progress
more than 80 million vaccines have now
been administered
last week 18 million doses were sent to
states
to pharmacies and community health
centers merck and johnson and johnson
competitors before now are teaming up to
speed up manufacturing
which means that we should have a full
vaccine supply for adults
by the end of may and to get shots and
arms more quickly
we've opened new vaccination centers in
a number of places in the place of my
birth oakland california in los angeles
in houston in dallas and arlington tampa
orlando
jacksonville brooklyn queens and upstate
new york
and one opened in philadelphia last week
others will open in chicago and
greensboro this week
and another two are coming to atlanta
and cleveland soon
so as you know we've all been busy and
we're doing this
all of this as i've mentioned as we
advance
our american rescue plan this plan is
big
and it is bold and it will help us beat
this virus
and build back our economy with this
plan
we will scale up our vaccination program
get relief to the small businesses that
fill your main streets
and get your schools safely reopened
the bill provides targeted support for
as many as nineteen thousand cities
towns and villages
and we know many of you are dealing with
budget shortfalls as revenues are down
and
of course expenses are up as a result
vital services have been cut and i know
you didn't want to
and we've lost more than 1.3 million
state and local government jobs
in just the past year in the aftermath
of the great recession
these kinds of cuts put a significant
drag on our economic recovery
and guys we can't let that happen again
[Music]
the american rescue plan will also get
fourteen hundred dollar checks
in the pockets of people who need them
most
and a three thousand dollar tax credit
per
child think about it this plan will
actually lift one in three black and
latino americans who are living
in poverty and lift them out of poverty
we will also lift half of america's
children
who are living in poverty out of poverty
i mean just think about that half of the
children
in our country who are living in poverty
won't be so the american rescue plan
um for that and so many other reasons is
and we are happy to say incredibly
popular
and the support for it is broad and it
is bipartisan
three in four americans support the bill
democratic and republican mayors and
local leaders have endorsed it
and of course of course so has the
national league of cities
and thank you for that and think about
it
two mayors just most recently a
republican from miami and a democrat
from st
petersburg wrote an op-ed about why they
support the plan
and they said in the op-ed quote
our people need help and as the
president would say
help is on the way today the american
rescue plan
is very close to becoming the law of the
land
and now we need to help ensure that
relief
is distributed equitably equitably
and that means we need to acknowledge as
so many of us do
we need to acknowledge the pandemic has
made
worse the fissures and the flaws and
failures
that already existed in our systems and
in our structures
we've seen that race and place
matter a lot in how well protected a
person is from the virus
or not and race and place have played a
role
in access to services so one way we're
addressing this is with our covid19
health equity task force this task force
stemmed from a bill i introduced in the
united states senate
to have a dedicated group of experts who
report on the disparities that exist
in the allocation of resources the task
force is required to make
recommendations
on how to solve for those problems and
local leaders are vital you
are vital to the solution so today
we have a big announcement and we're
actually making it right here with you
because it will have a direct impact on
the communities that you
serve our administration will offer
250 million dollars in grants
for localities to partner with community
organizations
on health literacy our goal
is to provide underserved communities
with the information they need
to stay safe and to get vaccinated
and remember information and education
of course
saves lives when folks have the
information and the education
they have the the tools that equip them
to take care of themselves
and their family we expect to fund
30 projects in urban communities and 43
projects in rural communities
for two years and i'm going to give you
some information on
on how you can can apply and and get
more and that is
um to apply through april 20th at and
i'm going to give you a website
minorityhealth.hhs.gov and we'll
follow up and get it for you um in
writing but
i asked the friends here please do work
with us
to put equity at the center of our
collective
response to identify those individuals
and communities who have been
overlooked and to connect them with the
resources
that are available and to connect with
them in a way that we renew
and in some cases establish trust
between community and those folks who
are elected
to serve those communities and also
we've got a child tax credit coming
that they can take advantage of so
please tell them about it
and tell them about the paycheck
protection program
and the loans there for small businesses
please tell you folks about how to get
vaccinated at pharmacies and community
health centers
and mobile units and please continue to
tell everyone you know
to wear a mask and this brings me to my
final point
the american people will continue to
look to you
as much as they look to me or the
president
because of your tireless efforts
because they know they can rely on you
they will continue to look to you for
answers
and for action and for comfort and for
hope
and i know it's not an easy job but what
you do
especially at this moment of crisis
couldn't be more important so thank you
again
for all you do i know it takes personal
sacrifice
and sleepless nights but know that the
president and i
are working right alongside you
so may god bless you and may god bless
america
thank you all
join us in welcoming the mayor of
huntington west virginia steve williams
in conversation with u.s secretary of
transportation
pete buttige
mr secretary welcome home
glad to have you with us today i'm
honored to
welcome you to the nlc's congressional
city conference
and we have individuals here who are
viewing this from hawaii to maine
down to florida and everywhere in
between and
they recognize a familiar face because
we know that prior to becoming
the 19th secretary of transportation in
january just i think it was just 33 days
ago
you served two terms as mayor of your
hometown of south
bend indiana and we know in south bend
you worked across the aisle to transform
the city's future
and improve the everyday lives of
residents we know that you're going to
continue to do that
in in washington so so mr secretary
33 days into it how are you
rolling up your sleeves and getting to
work at the u.s department of
transportation
well mayor first of all it's great
seeing you thanks for for your continued
leadership
and thanks for a chance to address
everyone who's gathered with the
national league of cities you you truly
represent the people who
are doing the work and uh the work
you're doing is is phenomenal especially
at a challenging
time like this for me as you might
expect it's been a
lively few weeks we got to work straight
away and there's not been a moment to
lose i've been focused on engagement
internally and externally internally
because there are about
55 000 employees here at the department
phenomenal
uh public servants and and people who
have such
uh remarkable experience and remarkable
commitment to to our mission so i've
been taking a lot of time
as a new city leader would getting to
know uh employees here and making sure
that
we're the best possible workplace and
that we're aligned as
as best as we can to meet the mission uh
and there's been a lot of
outside engagement uh participating in
events like like this one that i'm
thankful to be at
and of course a huge focus on making
sure in these first weeks that we
delivered this
rescue package that the vice president
was just talking about the senate vote
brings us one big step closer i want to
thank all of you
for the work you have done to
communicate to the public and
and perhaps educate many members of
congress about what this means
in our communities and of course now we
need to get this
back through the house over to the
president's desk uh with not a moment to
lose
and then we have an opportunity to work
on an economic recovery package that i
am
so enthused about the potential of
we're talking about a chance to build
back better across the country
and to to my way of thinking there are
moments that that come along that you
just can't dare miss
and we're in one of them both in terms
of the scope of the challenge
from our nation's reckoning over equity
racial and economic justice to the
climate crisis in front of us to
what covid19 has done to our communities
and economies
but also the opportunity side the
national
impatience to get something done and the
fact that the the economic conditions
and the political conditions
i think have us very well aligned to
come together and do big things when it
comes to
infrastructure i know this is not the
first administration
to arrive with high hopes on what we
could deliver
in terms of infrastructure but we're
determined to take advantage of this
unique moment this maybe once every
century moment that we're in
with your help in order to deliver and
so when i'm not
around this building getting to know my
new colleagues or engaging
uh with elected leaders like you i'm uh
working to
frame uh the right possibilities for
that and we'll be turning to you
uh of course both to inform and we hope
to communicate the importance of
uh the legislation that may be
materializing later on this year
mr secretary um we are coming upon
a one year into a crisis that's laid
bare
equity issues related to our health
structure
their economic structure and even the
fabric of our social structure and
you've just indicated
it's a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
for us
to be able to get things right the first
time so
in that regard how is it that the
department of transportation might be
able to
identify uh that once in a lifetime
opportunity
to transform our nation well
as every local leader knows issues of
equity and justice
are absolutely at stake in the choices
we make about
transportation and infrastructure we
know that the very same americans
disproportionately americans of color
who've been excluded
by design through american history from
economic opportunity
have also been those most likely to live
in neighborhoods with inadequate
transportation resources
or most likely to live in neighborhoods
where highway projects and other
investments often with federal money
have actually made things
worse by isolating people from one part
of a community
to another we got a chance to do
something about that we got a chance
right now to take our
history into account and even more
importantly
to take our future on board as we make
choices
that ensure that access to
transportation becomes a leveler an
equalizer
something that makes this country a more
fair and more just
place to be by the way this is something
that can't be separated
from questions of climate and
environmental justice very simple
example
is that we know that some americans are
disproportionately likely
to live close to highway thoroughfares
that have worse air quality and are
more likely to suffer from asthma and
other
conditions related to particulate matter
in the air which in turn
helps to explain one of the reasons why
we see disparities and who's most
vulnerable to covet 19.
all of this is connected the problems
are connected and so are the solutions
i'm especially energized by the
president's call for us to deliver
40 of the overall benefits of this
administration's investments
to disadvantaged communities we're
calling it justice 40
and the department of transportation has
a huge role to play here
so again this is something we can't do
just out of washington it's got to be in
partnership with local communities
but the bottom line is this is a top
priority here at the department
it's a priority of the president it's a
priority of mine and i know that as you
work to make sure that your communities
empower
everyone everyone to thrive we're going
to do everything we can to support you
in that work
so just how is the biden harris
administration
organizing around buildback better and
what's included and how would you be
working with local governments
on that well let me make clear we're
working now even before we get some of
those big pieces of legislation through
for example on the build grant formerly
known as tiger and the infra grant
formerly known as as fast
we're going to be working to make sure
that
those priorities are reflected even in
the discretionary grants you may have
noticed this
in the in the notice that went out to
infra if your community
is applying for that program but uh the
buildback better package represents a
whole new level
of opportunity at least it it can and
that's what we're trying to uh build
right now so the way i describe it is
we've got a one-two punch a two-step
plan now
step one is what we're in the middle of
right now american rescue plan that is
going to get shots and arms get checks
to families
it's going to help with things like
transit because we've got that support
for
transit agencies and local government uh
it's going to be what we really need in
order to get through this
tough tough moment that we've all been
in in our communities and our economy
hopefully that's just days away from
signature and then
we can talk about part two of that
two-step process and that's where we
have a chance i think to
put together a vision to build back
better that obviously
goes beyond what i work on here in the
department of transportation
it's really a nationwide and whole of
government opportunity but
you can't talk buildback better without
talking about build which is
infrastructure so what does that
actually mean well part of it is
modernizing uh introducing the things
that
we really need to get our infrastructure
to a world leading level i just can't
accept the american citizens are told to
settle for less
than a lot of people in other countries
when it comes to the resources they have
whether it's right around the
neighborhood and transit options
or whether it's traveling long haul
with some of the things that uh that
we've been asked to settle for with the
funding that goes into rail in this
country
but as every local leader knows this
isn't uh
going to get the job done if we're just
looking at things we might want to add
or introduce
you know take care of what we already
have we have so many roads
uh that are in tough condition the asce
the american society of civil engineers
just came out with that that famous
report card that they do every year
and once again we're seeing that our
roads and our bridges and other elements
of our critical infrastructure
are in rough rough shape that's why
we're thinking about the fix it first
strategy a lot around here which is to
make the communities have the resources
to take care of what you've already got
and adjust it maybe there's some areas
where
uh just as there are some areas where a
road needs to get wider there might be
some areas where a road needs to go on a
diet we ought to help with that too
especially if it saves you
on maintenance costs in the long run so
these are the kinds of things we're
thinking about but
i'm not going to be sitting in a room
here at the department and thinking it
up on my own
nor does the president envision this
being a strictly top-down
enterprise this is something that's got
to happen in dialogue and that's why
the listening session i was able to have
earlier with the
nlc leadership was so helpful and we're
going to continue to be listening as
well as speaking
on how best to frame this opportunity
which again i'm convinced is
one of those things that comes along
just once perhaps in a lifetime
and make the most of that opportunity to
provide the investments that american
communities need
and then we've got to make the case
we've got to sell it
because as we've learned with this
rescue plan just because something has a
commanding majority among the american
people democrats and republicans
and perhaps among american mayors and
city leaders
doesn't always mean that it gets a
rousing majority
up on capitol hill that's where the work
of
all of us doing that persuading that
engaging is going to be so important to
actually get something through
and as you know from your history of
south bend
uh the communication from the local
level to the members of congress
is the way to be able to to get things
done
earlier today with the board of
directors you heard
a full laundry list of what we're
attempting to do with infrastructure
we're prioritizing
sustainable infrastructure investment
with both safety and technology
focus so how can we partner together
with the usdot in these areas
well as you said local leaders are
already thinking about and acting on
opportunities around things like safety
and the use of technology
what i think dot can do is help provide
resources
help provide insights technology
sometimes
and that integrated view where you know
a department
like mine ought to be talking to a place
like the department of housing and urban
development about how we can mutually
support
transit-oriented development just to
take one example of the kinds of
interdepartmental collaboration that
aren't always part of the way people are
used to doing things in the federal
government but
as every local leader knows you you
can't get anything done without it
uh some of the things we're working on
sound very technical uh the notorious
m-u-t-c-d the
um i'm not even gonna try to state what
it uh
stands for so i don't get it wrong but
this uh no it's the manual on uniform
traffic control devices i think somebody
will tell me if i got that wrong
but you may notice something that almost
has the force of law because it lays out
the standards for
roadways and signage and actually a
seemingly dry and technical thing like
how that manual is written and what it
calls for could actually have a lot
of consequences in terms of how people
get around
in terms of safety even in terms of
equity and so
we're going to be working on those
technical dimensions as well as on
things like the big legislation we think
we might be able to get done
none of it happens without a rich
conversation with local communities
to hear what you're already doing on the
ground and find ways to support it
and to share what we're learning
cross-pollinating from one community
to another something that nlc already
does so well
we want to provide support for that kind
of thing in our department too
as you said you have the ear of your
members of congress too they pick up the
phone when the mayor calls
when a local leader calls and that's
going to be very important
in order to make sure that we have that
right kind of dialogue
you know so much is made of the
relationship between the federal
government and the states
but to me it's the relationship with the
local communities that is the most
dynamic interesting and important
in our federal system and we're bearing
that in mind on anything we might be
working on
uh whether it's grand visions for uh
upgrading uh
the rail network in this country or
whether it's trying to use our research
capabilities to give you better cheaper
ways to fill potholes that last longer
uh potholes being the enemy of every
local official
so all of these things will serve our
fundamental shared goals
safety climate resilience equity and
justice
and of course job growth and economic
strength
all of those things are possible if
we're working together
on the opportunities that infrastructure
and transportation represents
part of why i'm so enthused to be in
this job
um we have just about a minute left mr
secretary
now you're among just a few
thousand of your closest friends here at
nlc
um what can nlc what can we do
to help you build a more equitable
future and get more done
for our residents more quickly
well you're doing the work right now so
the first thing that we need you to do
is is
to succeed and to keep at it let us know
what you need and i don't just mean the
projects although
of course you'll be in that robust
process of going to bat for the worthy
projects that that we can
often help with with federal dollars let
me let us know
in the same way that you work with your
stakeholder community to make things
uh simpler dealing with the cities that
you run i want to do the same thing in
this department
if there's some process here some form
that's 10 pages but it could have been
five
and met the same goals if there's some
process it takes two years and
could have been six months and had the
exact same rigor
in terms of environmental or other uh
needs
let us know what that's like because i
want this to be a user-friendly
department uh
for our intergovernmental partners uh
and we'll we will be all ears
then as we shape up that common vision
i'm going to be turning you to build
public support and congressional support
for big investments
because we know without the big
investments we're just not going to be
able to get where we need to be as a
country
when it comes to our infrastructure
mr secretary we're awfully awfully proud
of you you have a friend in the
nlc we look forward to working with you
and thanks for being with us today
right back to you my friend in the
department and a lot of friends in
washington who would
be extraordinary what you're doing keep
it up and let us know how we can help
you
we are now pleased to welcome clarence
anthony ceo and executive director of
the national league of cities
[Music]
good afternoon national league of cities
uh really honored to be here today
to welcome two of our nation's leading
positions
to our virtual stage today for an
important
conversation regarding the national
strategy
on covet 19.
exactly one year ago local leaders were
gathered in washington dc for this very
conference
we were very likely one of the last
in-person conferences as the realities
of the covet 19 pandemic gripped our
nation
in eight weeks and months to come
local leaders you've been at the
forefront
of the response to this deadly virus
and this conversation could not be more
critical
to you as local leaders it is important
for
us to understand the biden
administration's view
on the current trajectory of the virus
the strategy for vaccine deployment as
well as how we
can continue to address the issues of
health equity and vaccine hesitancy
our guests are the familiar faces of the
administration's response
and i am so pleased to have them join
me here today in this important
conversation
nlc please welcome dr
anthony fauci who is director of the
national
institute of allergy and infectious
diseases
at the u.s national institute of health
where he oversees
an extensive research portfolio
focused on infectious and immune
mediated diseases he also serves as
president biden's chief medical advisor
and has served under six presidents
starting with
president ronald reagan
we also want to welcome dr
rochelle wielinski who is the 19th
director of the center for disease
control
and prevention and the ninth
administrator
of the agency for toxic substances
and disease registry prior to leading
the cdc
dr lewinsky served as chief of the
division of infectious
diseases at massachusetts general
hospital
and a professor of medicine at harvard
medical school good afternoon
doctors how are you guys doing very well
thank you miss anthony thank you for
having me
uh delighted thank you guys for being
here as well
let me start with you dr fauci you know
nearly 50 days into the biden
administration
where are we today in terms of the rates
of infection of this disease and your
perspective on whether
the worse is behind us
well right now even though we have seen
over the past
several weeks to a couple of months a
sharp decline in the number
of infections per day which were as high
as 300 000 to 400 000
a day the sharp decline is good news
but the sobering news about this is that
we've reached what is
looks like somewhat of a plateau
in the diminution of daily cases with
the seven day average being somewhere
around 60 to 70
000. so the good news is that it was
coming down the
sobering news is that it's starting to
plateau a bit and history
with this virus has told us when you
start to plateau
at a level as high as this
which is about 60 to 70 000 cases a day
that you are by no means out of the
woods and you've got to continue
to do the type of public health measures
that we talk about
all the time the masking the physical
distancing
and the avoidance of congregate settings
particularly
indoors when you talk about the worst
behind us
that could be possible because we have
vaccines that are now available that are
highly efficacious and safe
so the more people we get vaccinated and
the more quickly we do it
the better off we are but now is no time
to declare victory because we still have
a considerable amount of viral dynamics
that we're dealing with
yeah let me follow up on that because i
do think that one of the things our
delegates are asking
us is about the variance
how do the variants set us back in
cities towns and villages all over
america
well they they i wouldn't say they set
us back i say they they provide a new
challenge for us the new challenge
is that we have a situation
whereby you have viruses that are
circulating
that are not the original type of virus
they have mutations which then make them
be called
variants from the original which you
call
wild type and what the variants do that
they sometimes elude
the protection that you can get from
monoclonal antibodies which is a form of
therapy and they potentially not every
variant
but some can potentially evade
some of the protection that is given to
you
by the antibodies that are induced by
the vaccines that we're using
also some of the variants can spread
more rapidly
than the wild type varys and some of
them can even be more serious in the
sense
of making you more sick so we take them
very seriously
we monitor them and if necessary
we will modify our vaccines to address
them
you know one of the things that the
president has
done is taken significant measures to
increase the vaccine supply to
communities across the country
including you know like launching a
retail pharmacy program
and a fema reimbursement program to
states
so given these measures how quickly do
you think
we can vaccinate most of the residents
in america
well the president has said that by the
end of may
we will have enough vaccine to vaccinate
everyone in the country who is available
to get vaccinated in the sense of
uh adults and certain of a younger
population
in which the fda has allowed vaccination
for
how long it will take to get everyone
vaccinated as depending upon a number of
factors
one our logistical capability of getting
vaccine into people's arms i would
imagine that we could probably do that
within a couple of months following the
total availability
of vaccines somewhere this summer i
would believe
um that is really very important um
and i think that this is going to change
a lot of what we can
cannot do which i'm sure you'll hear a
bit more from
dr wolenski
so you know our municipal officials from
all of america is trying to figure out
what is the best role for them as it
relates to these
efforts and measures what can they do to
help
this issue related to the covet 19
response
well mr anthony the local elected
officials are the people closest to the
grounds in your community
i imagine you were elected officials
many of you
therefore the community trusts you the
best thing you could do
to help me to help dr walensky to help
all of the people who are trying to get
our arms around this
uh this pandemic as well as everybody in
the country
is to get your citizens to get
vaccinated
when the vaccine becomes available and
encourage them
not to pull back on public health
measures prematurely
in other words listen to the
recommendations of the cdc
regarding mitigation methods wearing of
masks
physical distancing they analyze this
they have the best epidemiologists in
the world
listen to what their recommendations are
thank you dr bauchie and uh now like to
turn to
dr lewinsky thank you so much for being
here today our municipal leaders are
just so
pleased to have this type of information
from you here today
thank you so much for having me mr
anthony and and to the nationalists
i know you all have put in an
extraordinary amount of work
and dedication over this past year
well thank you you know according to the
cdc statistics 50
52 of u.s population older than six
months
received the flu vaccine including
myself
during the 2019-2020 influenza
season if we vaccinated 52 percent of
u.s residents with the covet
vaccine would that be enough and what is
ccdc's target for vaccination
it's such a great question and
everybody's looking at this target for
herd immunity how many people do we need
to have vaccinated how many people do we
need to
that somebody with disease were to
interact with somebody else that that
person would be
protected and blunt further transmission
um the bottom line is no 52 is not
likely to be enough
we don't exactly know what the level is
um and
with increasing transmissible viruses dr
fauci just discussed
um we believe the level to be even
higher than we thought over the summer
so people in over the summer were saying
somewhere in the 60 to 70 percent
range people are now talking somewhere
in the 70 to 85
range the bottom line is that everyone
who is willing and wanting should roll
up their sleeves and get vaccinated
and everyone who's healthy enough um to
to encourage others to do so should set
the role model
to be um to to bring others into
vaccination and and i say this for
elderly people i say this for
immunocompromised people i say this for
people at the highest risk of disease
we really do need everybody willing to
roll up their sleeves if we're going to
blunt
further transmission and get to herd
immunity
now that's very helpful uh to to be able
to get the
public officials that kind of
information and i wanted to kind of
focus a little bit in
this issue related to the people of
color uh
particularly black americans who are
experiencing
more uh serious illness and death due to
the covet 19 than
than white residents in our communities
in 16 states that has
been released that's been releasing data
by race
white residents are being vaccinated at
a higher rate
in many cases two to three times higher
than people of color how should local
leaders be messed
messaging about the vaccine in order to
ensure
their residents have access and take
this vaccination
particularly in the black indigenous
latino hispanic and
other communities of color any advice to
our municipal officials
yeah this is such an important question
and what i will say
is we at the cdc i personally would
really like to emphasize how critical
this is i know that the administration
is deeply concerned about these
inequities
let me give you a little a few
statistics we know in this pandemic
latin uh latinos and hispanics are 2.3
times more likely to die
and african americans two times more
likely to die of covet 19.
we know data from the cdc over this past
um
the early first six months of this
pandemic um the
life expectancy dropped one year for uh
for all americans life expectancy
dropped 2.7 years for african americans
and 0.9 years for hispanic americans
and we know as you point out that um
while 65
of people 65 have vaccinated or white
only nine percent are hispanic and seven
percent african-american
these inequities have been deep they
have been long-standing
they're resulting in disparate health
outcomes and we have to fix this
um we have to fix this because this is
where the virus is this is
the communities that they are hitting
what i do know
is that we need to use all capacity in
order to do so
the federal government is working with
fema and with the cdc
to ensure that our community vaccination
sites are high volume 6000 person a day
vaccination sites
are strategically placed in high census
areas with so
high social vulnerability indexes in
disease
we're putting the federal pharmacy
program in pharmacies where we believe
they're working to reach the hardest hit
communities
we're putting vaccine in federally
qualified health centers for exactly the
reason
that you know that serve the
marginalized marginalized housed
as well as uh publicly housed so we're
working really hard to make sure vaccine
is getting to these people but what we
also need to make sure
is that you community members
members who localities people who know
your district people who know
your people mobilize your networks
because they don't necessarily want to
hear from me
they want to hear from you trusted
people in their communities
community-based organizations face
faith-based organizations
and the more people in those local
organizations that get vaccinated
and that serve the example for others
the more people will want to be
vaccinated
well i can say on behalf of the national
league of cities our
members are so committed to making sure
that everybody has
access to the vaccine and that there's
education to build that level of trust
that is needed in the communities of
color so we
are with you 100 i want to ask
both of you this question you know how
is the administration
thinking about issues of access
a little bit more granular and and why i
say that in many smaller
and more rural communities and also in
urban areas
access to broadband sign up for the
vaccination
is very limited and a streamlined system
to find out
where to get the vaccine can be
complicated
are there ways that local leaders can
help to best
address this issue for residents
you know i will say that um we know
we've had numerous challenges with the
access one is that we simply have had a
not enough
supply of vaccine and and so we as dr
fauci noted we know more supply is
coming we think that that is going to
improve dramatically in the weeks ahead
and we also know that there's a
remarkable amount of vaccine hesitancy
and we really
really need to reach people where they
are with regard to why they are hesitant
some it may just be because it's not
convenient for them they haven't been
able to access it digitally they haven't
been able to make the appointments or to
sit by the computer to try and
refresh and sign up for these
appointments some of it is because they
might not have understood
what how it was possible that the
science moves so incredibly fast and it
did with over a hundred thousand people
enrolled in these three vaccine trials
some of it is that they're worried about
their side effects um and really just
need to hear from others who've
been vaccinated that they did not have
severe side effects that we
like they were concerned about um and
some of it might just be convenience
they need to have a mechanism that's
after hours after work um on the weekend
so
all of these things together once we
have more vaccine i think we'll really
be
instrumental in getting more vaccine to
people i do
i'm really heartened by some of the
things i've heard in the community
ways that communities react to their
two numbers into the city of chicago
there were vaccine clinics that
for union members of community colleges
in
loveland texas there were vaccination
centers at a new public transportation
center
and in the metropolitan international
church in nashville tennessee the
faith-based efforts reach their
communities of color so
these are just three examples of how
really it is going to be
person by person community by community
that actually does this extraordinary
outreach to get people vaccinated
you know when the president has also
made it very clear that equity is
always on the top line front burner of
everything we do
and if you look at some of the things
that have already been put up we're
standing up community vaccine
centers uh about close to 500 of them
and they are going to be placed in areas
where demographically you have high
representation
of minority individuals also pharmacies
are going to get stocked
including pharmacies in particular areas
regions locations neighborhoods that
have a high minority
and finally there will be mobile units
that will go
out directly to not easy to access
areas as well as increasing the number
of vaccinated tourist people
who put vaccine into people's arms
and he's also established an equity
task force and there are people in the
white house
cameron webb and others and you have uh
dr marcela nunez smith who is the chair
of the
equity task force so equity is very much
on the front burner
of everything we're trying to do with
vaccines
thank you both for for answering that
because that is very important and i
think
that mayors and council members and all
of america
get this question about access uh
distribution
uh in my neighborhood or in another
neighborhood and why is that
area being selected over another
and they're trying to come up with
answers and you guys really are
in fact helping them to address uh their
residence
let me ask this question to uh dr
wilinski
uh once uh residents are vaccinated we
still need to continue with
safe practices that i've heard many
times that you guys have said the same
thing
distancing wearing masks avoiding crowds
washing hands today the cdc released
guidelines on what activities vaccinated
individuals can do
for many people they see this as
say a return to normal can you help us
understand the best way we should be
messaging
to our president because i do think that
uh that can uh send a mixed message if
we're not clear
yes that's such an important point so
i'm really proud of the
at least today but i do want to just
convey that this is
really a first initial step we
today have less than 10 of the american
population vaccinated so far we're
getting there and we're moving
really fast but we still have 90 people
who still have to protect and as dr
fauci earlier said we
still have 60 000 new cases a day
so we are really trying to strike the
balance of what vaccinated people can do
while also protecting those people who
remain unvaccinated
we as more people get vaccinated we will
have further guidance
as we follow the disease course in the
country follow the variance and the
amount of disease we will update the
guidance and importantly as we have
new data that continuously emerges to
how this vaccine is working
in these populations that are vaccinated
we will again update the guidance
for now what we say is in private
settings
in private settings um vaccinated people
can meet with unvaccinated people in
their own home
without masking or distancing which is
really
a really nice way for people to start to
be able to do the things with the people
that they love
in private settings we also say that
vaccinated people
can meet with members of one other
household
who might be unvaccinated as long as
members of that household
are not at risk of severe disease from
covid19
this does mean that a grandparent who's
vaccinated
might be able can visit her healthy
daughter and grandchildren as long as
they are not at risk of severe disease
this is with one other household so this
is
i believe a real important first step
to getting people back to be able to see
those who they love
and really to get them back towards
doing the things that we were doing and
enjoying proposed
pre-pandemic
thank you dr wolinski and we'll make
sure we get
that information out to our municipal
officials
it is again uh the national league of
cities and our
members are able to share
um i want to go move to both of you
on on this issue related to public
health professionals
because this has been a
virus a pandemic that impacted so many
lives and so many professions
and we've seen public health take a
significant hit
with estimates of more than 180 state
and local public health officials having
left their jobs in less than a year
depleting and even stymieing i'd say
our public health system just when we
need it
most with this mounting pressure and
threats that our public health officials
are facing
how is the administration working to
improve public health
and the role of local public health
officials what can cities do to
to support these efforts well that
that's a very important and troubling
uh issue that you bring up mr anthony
uh you know of all of the pandemic
outbreaks that i've had to deal with
over the
36 years that i've been directing the
infectious disease institute
i have never seen a situation that even
came
close to this with regard to
divisiveness
over ideology political ideology that
actually
swept over into the issue of public
health
where people as you mentioned correctly
in your statement
and your question that health officials
who push for
common sense well accepted
public health measures of wearing masks
physical distancing uh avoiding
congregate settings including indoor
are actually looked upon as the enemy
uh the enemy of getting the economy
opened
the enemy of getting people's jobs back
when in fact the common enemy is the
virus
not the health officials who are trying
to do as best as they can
to get this country out of this pandemic
grip that we're in and the way we do
that
is by adherence to public health
measures and you're right public health
officials
have been threatened and many of them
have left their position
the president is very well aware of that
and is encouraging everyone to look at
this
as a common fight also i might mention
the recently passed 1.9 trillion
dollar relief bill includes in it
a lot of resources that will be helping
the local
public health officials to do their jobs
better
as city leaders what you can do is
please
get behind your public health officials
they are totally dedicated to the of the
mission particularly for you locally
to the health of their community so
please continue
to give them your strong uninhibited
support
maybe a few things i will add first of
all i completely echo dr fauci's comment
um this is this this virus doesn't know
boundaries doesn't know
uh demographics doesn't respect doesn't
respect borders this
this afflicts us all and so we all have
to have a unified approach to fight it
the 2020 report from trust for america's
health reported that in the last decade
the public health works force in this
country has lost
56 000 jobs 25
of our current public health workforce
is actually expected to retire
in the next year we have a crisis of the
volume of people who are even
engaged in public health in this country
and that's why i really do believe
given that in the last 10 years we have
seen ebola we have seen zika we have
seen h1n1 and now of course we've seen
clover 19.
we do need a massive bolstering of our
public health infrastructure
our public health workforce our state
epidemiologists who
help sort of understand where these
outbreaks
occur and then our state labs who
actually do the diagnostics and the
surveillance
to ensure that we know about outbreaks
when they happen
that public health workforce has been
frail for years
and and you saw the manifestations of it
being frail
in what happened with clove at 19. i am
speaking a lot to these
uh these societies the public health
workforce estate epidemiologist public
health
labs um they they need support they need
um they need workforce they need
infrastructure
and so what you can all do is to
facilitate the support
on going to those places um public
health works really well
on when you don't hear from us because
that means all things have been averted
what you heard saw with covet 19 is we
did not have the capacity to avert
now though those points are very helpful
we're seeing that
in public office and public service
we're seeing a mayor's council members
out there
trying to get the food and
housing and they're contracting the
pandemic and we're seeing
quite a few having terminated their
lives because they're out there serving
we will lift up those public health uh
employees and officials and we will be
there uh to encourage them
um i have one final question before we
go to the audience questions
how can local leaders help you both in
your teams to
take this fight to the finish line
because we know
that in order for us uh to return
to what many normal
we have to be partners with both of you
well you use the word local leaders so
i would say show leadership and get out
there and
endorse the kinds of things the cdc says
endorse the kind of things that you hear
dr walensky and i
say on our three times a week
press conferences we're doing it because
we want to get this country
out of this pandemic and back to normal
we're not doing it because we want to
stay down
normal we're doing it because we know
that is the way
the quickest way to get to normal
so we need you we really do need local
leadership
to be able to endorse the kinds of
things that we say that is based on
science
and evidence
there is so much that's critical that's
riding on the next two months
um how quickly we vaccinate versus
whether we have another surge
really relies on march what happens in
march and april
and so what i would ask is that local
leaders as dr fauci said
the leaders demonstrate through their
own example
and through their own communities
mask squaring distancing all the public
health measures
demonstrate their willingness and
wanting this to get vaccinated
spread the word to local community
leaders and be part of the action
that gets us out of this
now we have some questions from a few of
our members uh
the first question comes from mayor
chastity wells
armstrong from kankakee illinois a
population of 26 thousand
uh the mayor says given the newness of
the vaccines
how can local leaders help the public
become more comfortable
without having longitudinal research
to study the potential of side effects
we have a similar question from a
council member rebecca via grand
san antonio texas population 1.5
million as well as council member
ellen uh smith from oak ridge
tennessee
who would you like to answer that
i'll ask both of you guys jump in
because these officials are excited
about hearing from you guys well maybe
let's go ahead and michelle go ahead
you know i know these are new vaccines
and they're new to us but the the
reason that this was possible is because
so much science was happening
around these vaccines before coven 19.
these were not
started around covet 19 there was an
extraordinary amount of research
on mrna vaccines that preceded
2020 and that made it possible to sort
of
jump start everything with with the
arrival of the mrna vaccines
um as i mentioned 100 000 people
rolled up their sleeves to enroll in
these clinical trials with
well which i would say 100 000 people
total so about 70 000 people
in the mrna vaccine specifically um
they've it's shown extraordinary safety
in that time
it was possible because so many people
volunteered so quickly
and in fact because there was so much
disease out there that we could
achieve outcomes quite quickly we have
seen that the anaphylaxis the severe um
allergic reaction that happens with
these vaccines
is happening at a rate of about four in
a million
that's extraordinarily low and very
consistent with what we're seeing all
other vaccines
and that reaction is is reversible so
what i would say is
we know a lot about these already um we
have an experimental research
um we have been doing uh following this
in our
safe program um in in at the cdc and
thousands tens of thousands of signed in
the largest uh vaccine safety program in
our
history and and so we are following the
data carefully and we just haven't seen
concerning signals
you know you use the word longitudinal
research people keep asking dr wolinski
and i
what about these long-term effects that
you might be missing
since this vaccine has only been
involved in being administered for a
year
well you know when you look at the
history of axonology and you talk about
long-term effects not the immediate ones
that dr walensky mentioned such as the
anaphylactic reaction but some unknown
bizarre thing that might happen sometime
afterwards that you could miss in the
history of vaccinology
when you look at what the fda and the
cdc and others have looked at
historically
almost all of the vactine effects that
occur
beyond just the vaccination date
occur between anywhere between 15 and 45
days
after the administration of the dose
it is for that reason that the fda
requires that before you allow a vaccine
to be given
to the american public you must wait 60
days
from the time that 50 of the people in
the trial
receive their last dose so you're well
beyond
historically when essentially all of the
long-term
side effects occur that's the reason for
the 60-day weight
so in addition to the long-term
follow-up
that dr walensky mentioned to you you
don't even get a chance to get the
vaccine
until you have that 60-day waiting
period
this is next question is an important
question
and it's uh cities need help getting
vaccines straight to their communities
to set up mass
vaccination hubs that are equitable
and not political how is the federal
government roll out specifically through
the fema community vaccination centers
working
to ensure that max vaccine vaccine sites
are an area most impacted by covet 19.
so the cdc sits down with fema and looks
at both
census and social vulnerability index
and then the places where these mass
vaccination sites could be placed
to really hit a large number of people
as well as
where those people would are maximally
where there's
uh the highest social vulnerability
index from there they also send
mobile units so they take from the mass
vaccination centers they're really
trying to do a whole lot of
outreach and so we really do map
where the the highest census is with the
highest social vulnerability
and then try and do the mobile units
from there
anything to add dr fauci no
actually exactly what dr wolinski said
and what i said in the previous comment
about
community vaccine centers mobile units
pharmacies
with the thought in mind that equity
must be addressed
at every single point and maybe one
other thing to add that um
the the this past week this past week
and a half
we're really rolling out and ramping up
our federally qualified health centers
and we really to over 250 across the
country
we really do believe that that also with
more vaccine on board getting to more of
those efficacys
will reach more hard to hit populations
well let me uh say thank you to both of
you dr
valchee as well as dr winsky
um for joining us this afternoon and
sharing your
optimism but also bring your knowledge
officials all over america and
i have to tell you that you are so
valued
in america without your knowledge
without your advice on a daily basis i
don't
think we would be where we are in
america
and i can tell you that the optimism
that america feels right now
is because of the information the
science the data
and the advice that you're giving our
communities
and mayors and council members all over
america
value your advice so thank you all
so much for your time i appreciate it
and one thing i will say any person that
has a
the name anthony in their name
they are really blessed and i do
appreciate
you guys every day as well as you uh dr
lewinsky
so thank you all thank you for having us
let's welcome back and i'll see first
vice president mayor vince williams
thank you clarence dr fauci and dr
wolinski
for such an important discussion on
where we are in combating
this pandemic this is a critically
important issue
this is a good time to mention that this
is
a special vaccine boot camp for us this
afternoon
i hope to see you there all right my
friends
we are officially finished with our
first general session
enjoy the fantastic workshops and
evening events
and we will see you back here tomorrow
for
two more general sessions have a
wonderful afternoon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you